today is our last full day of the month
beautiful skies to start off the morning
but we see some high clouds moving in
we're going to find out if those clouds
will bring us any rain lots of 30s
around the valley it's cold you need
coats this morning had a beautiful
finish to the weekend yesterday 65
degrees and sunshine for our sunday man
it was pretty 32 at red rock we've got a
few breezes up there at kyle canyon
right now they've been up to about 15
miles an hour 64 today four degrees
above the norm of 60 for the last day of
january so not bad at all but we will
keep a lot of those high clouds around 6
42 officially the sunrise this morning
and 506 is the sunset we need rain now
we're going to get high clouds with no
rain today but boy this is how we finish
off the month of january rainfall wise
last rain really the only rain for
january was on the 18th of the month six
hundredths of an inch officially other
areas did pick up more but that's where
we are we should have over a half inch
at this time of year and we are already
way behind they had plenty of rain
across the northeast of course over the
weekend plenty of snow and hurricane
force winds little island of nantucket
that's off the coast of cape cod
massachusetts as we have some video
there for you to show you that it was
swamped as the hurricane force winds
were blowing in along with snow they had
83 mile an hour winds clocked right here
in nantucket this is a beautiful little
island in the northeast very very
popular with summer retreats and you
know vacationers but you could see their
houses were just cut off all the streets
submerged in water there but they did
have some areas that got up to what two
feet of snow around boston and whatnot
so they're cleaning up a lot of power
outages trying to get the power back on
back here at home a little snow through
the northern rockies and a cold front
way up north is going to blast through
our area late tomorrow with north winds
to follow these high clouds are all
coming in off a low off the southern
california coast again we're staying
very dry we're not looking for rain so
we deal with the high clouds today with
more clouds tonight and into tuesday
morning as we start february tomorrow
mid 60's we'll see if we can make it to
mid 60's today depending on how thick
those high clouds get through the
afternoon and then tomorrow afternoon we
should get some nice sunshine back but
that cold front will pass through late
tomorrow with north winds behind it and
it also is going to drop temperatures
more than 10 degrees look at those low
50s on wednesday and thursday groundhog
day
those winds are going to be up maybe 30
miles an hour so yeah groundhogs
blinking in the wind on wednesday but we
get back into some nice easy 60 for the
weekend